hello and welcome to this episode of the
apogee accelerator series
in this video we'll demonstrate how to
expose your apis to external consumers
on the internet via apogee
when you first provision an apogee X
instance one of the steps you'll need to
decide is whether you want to allow
traffic from external clients by
themselves newly created apogee X
instances are only accessible to clients
within your Google Cloud Network
internal API consumers can reach your
apis using apogee's internal IP address
but they won't be visible to external
consumers
while this might be fine for some
organizations many need to expose their
apis to external consumers over the
internet
using Google Cloud load balancing you
can provide external access to your
apogee instances wherever they're
located
Google Cloud load balancing is a
globally distributed software-defined
managed service for all your API and
application traffic
with Cloud load balancing you can also
enable Cloud armor for Waf and DDOS
protection or leverage Cloud CDN for
Global caching using Google's Edge
Network
to expose an apigee X instance to the
internet simply deploy an external load
balancer in your Google Cloud VPC
you'll assign an external IP address and
host name to this load balancer and this
is where your external consumers will
connect
apogee's provisioning tools such as our
step-by-step wizard offer to create an
external load balancer for you during
the setup process and this is the
quickest way to get started if you'd
like to enable external access
however if you decide to begin with
internal only access and later realize
you need to expose apis externally this
sample will show you how
there are a couple of ways to connect
the external load balancer to your
apogee X instance
in this sample we leverage private
service connect or PSC to connect to the
apogee instance
you can find more information about
these options in our documentation
now let's see how to deploy this sample
in order to run this sample you'll need
an apogee X instance provisioned with no
internet access configured
as a user you'll need permissions to
configure access routing
this can be granted through the compute
Network admin role
you'll also need the ability to create
environments in apogee and this can be
enabled using the org admin or the
environment admin role
to deploy this sample you'll also need
the command line tool shown here
if you're using Google Cloud shell these
are already installed
we've included a cloud shell tutorial
which you can simply click to quickly
get started
now that you're in the cloud shell
environment you can follow the
step-by-step instructions
first change to the directory for this
sample
to deploy the sample first open up the
env.sh file and set the configuration to
reference your apogee project VPC
Network and subnet
next run the included script to deploy
the load balancer components
this process will take some time to
complete while certificate provisioning
occurs
when the script completes you should see
a message showing the external runtime
hostname and a sample curl command
run the curl command to send a test
request
you should see a success response
returned along with the response body
apogee Ingress is healthy which
indicates the instance is reachable via
the external URL
if you see an SSL Error wait a second
and try again
now let's take a quick look at what
components were created
go to the apogee management UI at
apogee.google.com under the admin
environments section you should see a
sample environment
under the environment group section you
should see a corresponding group with a
hostname that was created
for this sample we use nip.io to provide
a DNS entry based on the external IP of
the load balancer
apogee uses the hostname of incoming
requests to Route API calls to the
correct environment
under the instances section you can see
the PSC service attachment
the external load balancer connects to
this
next switch to the gcp console and
select load balancing under Network
Services
you should see the load balancer that
was deployed by The Script
if you click the load balancer you'll
see the details page showing the
external IP address and port number and
the TLs certificate that was provisioned
with the external nip.io hostname
at the bottom of the load balancer
Details page you can see the backend
configuration
the backend service contains a network
endpoint group or neg that points to the
PSC service attachment we saw before
now you've seen how simple it is to
create an external load balancer in
front of apogee
when you're done with the sample you can
provide us with your feedback and then
you can use the cleanup script to delete
the configuration that was deployed to
your Google Cloud project
we hope you found this useful and if you
enjoyed the video please hit the like
button below you can also subscribe to
our channel to see more videos in the
apogee accelerator series and if you
have questions please post them on the
apogee Community thanks for watching